It's the job of law enforcement to have guns and to decide when to shoot.
You just do not want the average citizen
carrying a gun in a crowded place.
Former New York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg made that comment after an armed citizen
may have averted a mass shooting by
killing a gunman at a Texas church.
It hasn't aged well.
How convincing can Bloomberg's "only cops should have guns" message be
to Americans who have seen and shared fresh examples of unjustified and brutal police conduct?
Or who have witnessed scenes of rioters and looters putting their lives and property at risk
because law enforcement agencies failed to protect them?
The NYPD and the mayor did not do their job last night.
A good many Americans took responsibility for their own safety, including people who fully support
protests against police misconduct, but see no reason to allow themselves to be victimized by hotheads
and opportunists.
In St. Paul, Minnesota black residents stood armed guard against looters outside local businesses.
Business owners in Kirkland, Washington did the same.
A Bellevue, Washington cigar shop owner chased off looters at gunpoint.
They were acting in the tradition of the so-called "Roof Koreans,"
who defended their stores during the 1992 LA riots.
I think one of his purposes is he wants potential looters to see it.
I think he wants people, all of them up
there, they want people to see that they are armed
and that you enter their properties at some risk.
Many police departments conceded the limits of their
abilities.
In Florida Sheriff Grady Judd advised Polk County residents to shoot looters.
High-profile psychologist Scott Barry Kaufman, a gun control supporter, marveled on Twitter
that when he called Santa Monica Police over protests related confrontation,
they told him, "Sir the city is under attack. Do what you have to do."
For those who have been advising Americans for years that we should lay down our own weapons
and trust armed government employees to
protect us and treat us with respect
2020 has been a massive reality check.
The year so far has demonstrated, once again,
that the police can't be relied on to defend our lives and property,
and often pose threats themselves.
It's the job of law enforcement to have guns and to decide when to shoot.
If we were to follow the advice of those who would disarm us, we'd be even more at the mercy
of Derek Chauvin and his buddies, and anybody else with ill intent.